good morning Hank it's Saturday saturday
Saturday that's right Hank it's that
rarest of flowers a Saturday Brotherhood
2.0 video and not only is it Saturday
it's also questioned Tuesday the day
that I answer real questions from real
nerdfighters I want to meet you that's
not a question but I'm still happy to
provide an answer you can meet me this
Monday like the day after tomorrow at
the Elizabeth Public Library in
Elizabeth New Jersey at 4 p.m. or if
it's more convenient to you also be in
Sydney Australia at 7 p.m. on June 3rd
more info in the sidebar
do you have upper-body strength yeah
only like a ton of it even though that
ottoman was Hollow I'm still sweating a
little how's life good thanks just dad
answering some questions what's your
favorite color peep one of my problems
with peeps is that they don't change
flavor when they change color and I've
always believed that flavor and color
should be correlated I have the same
problem with M&Ms how do I get my
youtube videos to load faster well it's
helpful if you're traveling very close
to the speed of light while you're
uploading nerd jokes nerd jokes hair
jokes
are you going to answer this question no
absolutely no snoot I just answered it
why do your questions get louder as you
go because I'm hurrying trying to fit in
all the questions who created the
original dftba acronym my friend katie
else why don't you accept my facebook
friend request I'm really sorry but
Facebook won't let me have any more
friends seriously zebras or monkeys I'll
tell you one thing I prefer zebra
monkeys - monkey zebras we got a problem
with me no but I am happy to ask someone
on your behalf favorite mountain goat
song up the wolves which Hanks book any
good AK I still haven't read it have you
lost weight don't be mean favorite joke
Billy was a chemist son - Billy's no
more what he thought was h2o was h2so4
hey what's your Wii tennis score $23.99
favorite punctuation interrobang
John will the world end in 2012 oh come
on eschatological anxiety is so 1999
what's your favorite part about
libraries free books also secret
superhero librarians how do you get a
nerdfighter to notice that you
romantically like him I find that the
best way is to say nerdfighter I
romantically like you has your opinion
on zombies vs. unicorns change since
2007 only in the sense that I hate
unicorns more than ever do you think
anyone actually reads books anymore I
don't just think it I have like
extensive empirical evidence that people
still read books is it okay if I T
your happy dance during my aerobics
class well first off I don't think that
happy dances can be copyrighted and
second off yes now it's not just an
exclamation of happiness but also
permission to use my happy dance in your
aerobics class Hank thanks for the truly
made of awesome song this week
nerdfighters thanks for all your
questions if you got more leave them in
comments and Hank you'll see me tomorrow